Sù khôi xù hay bốn, chính bình không tích tầm thật đầy rối lực của Ngà.
Chưa dài gần 2018, xài cạnh hơn bối bài mát,
xù hay bốn được chạm bị hai đậu cơ phản lệ mạnh mẽ xà tuần á lời hai miếm muốn em,
cho tốc độ vượt mắt một.
Tầm bay lên tới 20 năm trong kilomét,
sân bay hơn bối một nghiêm mẹc,
khả năng lau cao bột chăm năm bối mẽ trên dầy.
Wai đã o reo n' artiến tiến,
giúp phát hiện mục tiêu từ 1 chăm năm 2019,
hoạt động hiệu quả cả trong điều kiện khó khăn.
Sù hay bốn măng theo khó phút khí khổng lồ,
tên lợ không đối không, rơ sảo nơi, rơ bởi bà,
tên lợ chống ra đã cả hát nằm,
tên lợ hành trình cả hát nằm chính,
cùng nhiều loại bọn mạnh như cả AB năm trong ca rồi.
Ô đáp và Rốt Két,
lợ át hát xấu thái bà hai miếc bà lì.
Sù khôi xù hay bốn,
một điều tượng của sức mạnh tấn công tầm thật,
khiến mọi mục tiêu dưới mặt đất phải xe chừng.
Bạn đã sẵn sả khám phá sức mạnh thực sự của chính lâu cơ này chưa?